So, Wendy want me to start talking, or just like as soon as the video starts.
Okay.
You can pause, also press, you can press this if you want to pause.
So I can start narrating even when the video is going?
Yes.
Okay.
I haven't fully... got used to these new mads yet.
Um...
Yeah.
but the mats felt really good today the motions felt good
and
motions are a little bit stiff today
okay um i like the
today's flow was really good today's the mind doing things pretty good it's just
when you when i was going on this
mat um i maybe could have gotten more used to it and get a little more time familiar with it
but overall the feeling and motion excuse me executing everything
went better than i thought i expected um i could improve on maybe going a little bit more harder
and
put don't put too much pressure on certain movements because
today overall was a little more shaky than usual but the entire movement was yes
yeah